hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the clutch chest international
we are at game 12 which is the final
game and Fabi is leading the event by a
two-point margin so if this game ends in
a draw or by Fabi winning Fabi wins the
entire event and if Magnus manages to
get a win then Magnus gets three points
as this is also a clutch game yes again
it's the the weirdness of the event and
then Magnus wins the event so without
further ado let's check it out and yeah
also I just wanted to mention yeah we
almost had a second incident with the
mailman as I was just gonna record this
video and then I thought now maybe I'm
just gonna have a glass of water before
recording and I went to grab a glass of
water and in that moment the another
mailman came so we avoided the second
mailman for this video hopefully there
will not be a third one so getting back
to the game Magnus now with the white
pieces opens with c4 he goes for the
English opening and E 5 by Fabi now we
have Knight to c3 Knight to f6 and g3
now at the calls Bremen system and
Bishop to b4 we have E for now and we
already had this opening like I think
three videos ago where we mentioned that
it is not possible to win the pawn this
way because Queen e2 will just kick away
the night and then win the e5 pawn but
we didn't mention the rush of characters
on c3 is the the most common move here
so this is what Fabi goes for we have B
captures on c3 and here castles and now
what you would see here will not what
you would see here but there is one game
in the database where Bishop the g2 was
played from the 2019 video World Cup
between a loose time custom Journal and
Evgeny but EV but here Magnus goes for
f3 and it is a new move in the position
so already as of move six we have a
completely new game so far we continues
and he continues with b5 the idea is
that he wants to get his Bishop into the
game very quickly and also he wants to
remove one of the defenders of the d5
square so if captures let's say D 5 and
the Fabi immediately wants to open up
the center since Carlson's King is still
on a1 and Magnus hasn't really developed
any of the pieces that to even consider
castling so Magnus goes for d4 instead
doesn't mind that that b5 pawn and eek
actress on d4 we have seek after sandy
for n now be captures and see four or
five we grabs the c4 pawn and now again
if Bishop captures you mess up White's
pawn structure with d5 and it is very
risky since the king is still anyone so
Magnus goes for e5 instead he wants to
keep the center closed and now well you
could go for a rook to e8 and then force
white continue development Fabi moves
the knight Knight to d5 and here we have
Bishop captures on c4 finally going for
that capture with Bishop to be 7 by Fabi
and now Knight to h3 finally preparing
the castle
we have d6 preparing to open up the
center and now Magnus castles and here
we have Knight the d7 preparing Knight
to b6 but also just a threatening to win
a pawn here with characters characters
and of course characters so rook to e1
adding a defender to the pawn now if I
betrayed once captures captures and now
Knight 7 to b6 with pressure on the
bishop so Magnus moves the back Bishop
to b3 and if you look at the position
now it's equal material Magnus with the
bishop prepare and well Fabi with a lot
safer King Carlson's King is very very
loose here and it could be could be
easier to attack to attack so here a
Fabi has to decide how to continue this
game and he could go for something like
C 5 C 4 and so on since C pawn is
already a passed pawn so it might not be
a bad idea to start pushing it however
Fabi first
decides to develop the Queen he connects
the rooks creates the the two bros for
life and he runs into some trouble now
because here by placing the Queen and
East 7 he gives Carlsen a very very
lucrative idea so to say so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the move
calls and played here while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and sacrificing the pawn and for opening
up the diagonal for your dark square
Bishop and for the
we just want to enjoy the show it's East
six and now what you've done here is
that you've opened up this diagonal for
your dark square Bishop and well if if
if F captures then you've also messed up
a black's pawn structure in front of the
King a little bit and you also will have
created a nice target on e6 not
capturing the pawn is a bit
counterintuitive because by playing f6
well you've played f6 but also you've
created white this beautiful past epon
however it might not it might it might
not be all that bad since you might be
able to to attack it later on however
Fabi decides to accept the challenge he
plays F captures on e6 and now that
Crosson has a target here and he goes
for a Knight to g5 he puts pressure on
the pawn here and Fabi has to decide how
to defend a do you play some like Queen
f6 give up the pawn and try and get your
Queen into the game maybe with an attack
on the rook here you could go Bishop to
c8 the guard upon this way but Fabi goes
rogue to f6 it makes sense developing
while defending and also you've prepared
to bring the other look into the game
however now Magnus has Queen to c2
already putting pressure on the pawn
here and you have to defend it somehow
now you can either play g6 or you could
play rook to g6 Fabi decides for rook to
g6 but this again doesn't work so feel
free to pause the video and find it the
winning move for Magnus while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on removing the defender of the h7 pawn
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's rook captures on e6
and here you don't really have any good
moves for Fabi for example if you
capture with the rook then Queen
captures on h7 check King f8 and this is
mate as the night covers the f7 square
and another option after rook captures
and e6 is that you could maybe go for
Queen to f8 you just move the Queen
however then it's rook captures and g6
captures and Queen captures and g6 again
threatening Queen h7 mate black will of
course make some room for the King with
Queen f6 now the
it's where has been vacated for the king
however queen h7 check King to f8 and
now you can start pretty much doing
anything Bishop III checking yet you can
bring the rook into the game with
checking d7 and now let's say Queen h3
check and you don't really have any good
options here if King to c6 then rookie 6
check wins the Queen and if you go
somewhere like King to d8 it's not much
better since 96 check now you either go
here or you go here and wherever you go
you run into a lot of nasty discoveries
so we can check both options as it's
very interesting so for example if King
Teti 8 then you get to just Knight
captures on g7 with check King f7 and
queen to h7 again threatening a lot of
nasty discoveries and there's not much
you can play here for example if Queen
captures and g7 rook East 7 check the
knight is pinned so you cannot capture
and now it's just mate King has to move
now you capture here with check King
King again has the move away taking f5
and I'll let say Bishop to c2 and this
is now checkmate so this is what happens
if you move the King in front of the
rook if you move the King in front of
the Queen let's say go King to c8 then
again a lot of nasty discoveries are
happening Knight to the c-5a discover to
check from the Queen King b8 and now you
get rook to e8 check and it's completely
lost for example if Knight here then
Knight to d7 is checkmate and it's a
check made by fork not not very often a
seen a nice Royal fork checkmate and if
you don't cover up with the night if you
cover up with the bishop it's not much
different you just remove the defender
of the d7 square by capturing here so
just rook captures captures and now 97
check again picks up the Queen so not
not a lot of fun here for Fabi so you
cannot ignore the rook you cannot
capture the rook with the roof so Fabi
does the only thing he has left which is
Queen captures on e6 gives up the Queen
we have Knight captures and rogue
characters but it's not all that all
that terrible as Fabi now does have a
bishop well up basically a piece and the
rook for the Queen so there is there is
still hope
but now Magnus employ
the Bishop to b2 and the bishop air from
hell is now fully operational
so Bobby starts bringing the rook rook
888 he doubles up on the e-file and now
Bishop the d4 just preparing to remove
the defender of of the night here and of
course you also cannot move the night
since the the rook on d6 would hang so
King to h8 it makes sense to move the
King away from this diagonal and now
Queen to f5 again with the same idea
just Bishop characters either allows you
to capture here or if Knight captures
then the rook would hang so be sure to
see it now fob is hoping for rook to e1
check the pick up cross since Queen here
but Carson just moves that we have Queen
to h5 and now it's a very dangerous for
example Bishop - C - if it comes there
will not be all that much you can do to
prevent checkmate for example if rook
aged 6 you can just capture it either
capture it since its pinned here or you
can just capture this rope which will be
checkmate
so the rooks cannot be unpaired so here
Fabi played c5 he wants to remove the
bishop from this diagonal and Magnus
captures that he says okay Bishop
captures and c5 but now rook c5 again
pushing the Queen back Queen f7 and now
Bishop to h3 yeah it seems very
dangerous however the White King does
have the f2 Square to escape - so it's
not all that big of a deal
and here well you could go for something
like a Bishop to d4 and if the rook
moves let's say look here then you have
this of g7 checkmate crossing goes for
four well also a very nice idea he goes
for Bishop to f8 and now he's
immediately threatening checkmate so not
much you can do here Bobby tried rook to
e1 check rook captures any one rook
captures anyone with check King F - the
king is on the run rook to f1 check King
tehy - that's naughty - King to e2 and
now Knight to c3 check but here crossing
just played King to d3 and it was in
this position unmoved 31 that Fabiano
Caruana resigned the game magnus wins
which means he gets three points for
this win as it is a clutch game and it
is a Magnus who wins the event by a
at one point margin so I hear you
resigned as there are no more useful
checks there are no tricks if the night
was here you would have let's say rook
captures here Queen captures and Knight
to e5 check picking up with the Queen
however it's not so you don't and while
you could give some checks let say
Bishop f5 check hope to survive
checkmate
but white will just capture on c3 and
now if rook actress on f3 checking b2
rook after checking a3 there are no more
useful checks and there are no more ways
to add to create any any sort of
environment where tricks would be
possible
so of course Fabi knows that and after
King to d3 he resigns the game and here
is a here is a tweet well two tweets
basically by just 24 for those of you
who are not on Twitter
something Magnus said after the game he
said that regarding this last game that
the way it went was a dream since
everything just worked out very well and
I didn't really have to squeeze it out I
just could go for the jugular at any
early point and that was it at an early
point and that was it
and also Magnus praises Fabi by saying
fabi's made incredible strides in rapid
and blitz he's playing the next Magna
Steyr tournament and I think he's very
much a force to be reckoned with judging
by the way we played today he was as
deserving a winner as I was and he
deserves credit for a very good match
and it's not well some two years ago for
example every at the elite players were
saying that Fabi is definitely like like
a really a force to be reckoned with in
classical but he's not all that
impressive in blitz and rapid and then
of course after losing to Magnus in the
World Chess Championship match he he
went to head-to-head with Magnus in 12
classical games which all ended in a
draw but then when the time format
became faster Magnus was of course the
clear favorite and it does make sense
that Fabi has made improvement in both
rapid and blitz as he is also hoping to
challenge Magnus again for the title and
well who knows what will happen in
classical but if it turns again to rapid
or blitz
Fabi will of course be ready which is
what Magnus confirms here so that's the
game and
the coverage of this event I do hope you
enjoyed it I will I would like to thank
abeer Majumdar JAL Herman's Suleiman
sorte Stephen Bevan and Russell light
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here I'm thankful for watching
and I will see you soon
starting the coverage of something new
continuing the Morphy saga we are going
to check up on the POC champs
championship since we only cover one
game of that and you know of course on
your wonderful suggestions and
everything else that happens in the
chess world so once again thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day